at first glance, the
decision-
making structure regarding the spending of the funds that come into the pot from this allocation is recognizable as
democratic so far the idealistic
part of my description the
realistic partly
another one, funds that are available are
taken and
those to be paid for with these funds are taken  bills at the
end of the year are usually postponed from october
to the next year and the
first three months of the following
year the available funds are used to pay
the bills for the last third of the
past year this is
a small part of our household
reality that we do every year  about what brings me
to the barricades that i
don't want to hide here is who
criticizes stepping out of the capital cities
in unison and whether that sees
social democrat governments or
liberal governments or
christian democratic governments
gave the answer that he again the brussels
can not with ge  ld circumvent
the hypocrisy that exists in
budgetary policy in europe this can
hardly be topped
we need more transparency and
more transparency can be achieved through more
own funds because then
we can more clearly
identify where the money comes from and who
decides how it is to be collected  also
those who decide on the issue
and thus identifiable
for the citizens who
bears the responsibility